comment ça s'est passé bizarre oh c'était bien nous
avons couru sur la plage nous avons rencontré marques nouvelle
maîtresse ambre il faisait super chaud es-tu
jaloux
je ne suis pas oui j'ai eu l'impression d'être une fille folle
cela fait monter la moyenne de notre groupe tout
simplement pas freaking soeur sage chérie es-
tu sûr que tu n'es pas en colère parce que le
laisser sortir est bien mieux
que d'avoir à dire aux flics que tu ne
voulais pas la serrer dans ses bras à mort ce que je
j'ai besoin d'elle, je dois admettre que
Cape, j'ai en fait un point sur le fait qu'elle
élève la moyenne du groupe, vous vous
souciez si je fume
non, j'en veux un pour ce jour,
fumez des mecs quand je veux que vous regardiez
Boyd, cela devrait être bon
là où nous trouvons  Plus de maîtresses, je
vais avoir le centre de désintox